that's like a very personal question to
ask a stranger oh my god okay I might
need a second
Lulu oh man this is on the spot huh
oh man what is the worst decision that I
made in the last year or so besides
doing the [ __ ] Oh probably not
writing postcards as frequently as I
said I would to my grandparents I would
say moving in with someone that is in
wasn't fully in love with me so I just
kind of started a horrible downfall now
we're stuck here and not knowing what to
do why do you feel like you're stuck
well you're stuck in a lease for a year
and it's only been three months and yeah
hook up with someone that was someone
else's boyfriend's did it don't feel
great about it
Oh God what's worst decision I've made
recently well I got engaged to a Greek
man that I met on a plane and I moved
over to Greece and lived on an island
with him until I found out that he was
partially crazy and then I moved back
that was a bad decision because it took
me like 36 hours to get back to the
States from this remote little island
that we were on so that was definitely a
bad decision but at least I didn't marry
him
so I'm allergic to bananas
[Music]
I haven't had them in like a few years
so I thought maybe my allergy went away
I had some banana bread it was not good
never doing that again allergies do not
go away sometime so
thankful to be live choosing to go to
Walmart
instead of Target that was a big this
big mistake price is right but the
customer service and the people is on
the bad level should have gone a target
I was like you want to pay a couple
bucks more get the target experience you
know Walmart I peed in a dryer and then
turned it on
I honestly don't know I think it was a
deer oh I can tell that to the camera
I kissed a guy yesterday I didn't I that
was my words I think maybe partying a
little bit too much in certain points of
it and taking a lot on my body for those
getting caught up going out a lot and
socializing and then maybe like just
neglecting more of my health nice
balance not getting rid of more stuff I
just moved so I had to move
cross-country with an awful lot of stuff
and I think it would have been easier if
I just kind of let go some of that stuff
but it was like I held onto it for
whatever reason it was hard to get rid
of got rid of a lot but probably could
have done without a lot more I don't
know I tend to consider most of my
decisions pretty good so I have to
really think about that
also tend to do a pretty good job of
erasing any bad decisions have made from
my memory my 90 year old grandma flew
home from San Diego to Milwaukee and I
thought she would be okay to fly by
herself and she was scared and she was
alone and she's 90 and that was a bad
choice on my phone so that is the worst
decision I've made in the last thing two
days to go to the Balboa Zoo because
it's really quite horrific to see
animals caged not going to church this
Sunday racking up $800 in credit card
debt that's definitely the worst
decision I've made so far getting into
business with the wrong person
yeah I would definitely say convenience
in other people
the worst decision I've made in the past
year I told myself I was gonna eat
healthy and then one of my co-workers
said oh there's a bunch of free donuts
and I ate like two of them gaining
weight back that I lost like I lost like
50 pounds and I'm getting like almost
all of it back so I think that's the
worst decision I've made trying to hold
on to the past with my ex when we split
up I just I just let go a lot sooner
I couldn't let go because I've been with
her for so long that you know I've just
enjoyed all those other memories but
when I started doing things for myself
[Music]
her or doing things to try to get back
the pass
you're getting to school late every day
yeah
because basically now I have to make it
all up I go into Saturday school
everyday so every Saturday except that
would be my worst mistake you good
school everyday yeah I just take too
long to get ready I moved into a fully
furnished apartment that costs 929 a
month and I make a little over a
thousand a month so that was not a not a
good move on my end I I guess I'd have
to say like I don't feel like I've made
a bad decision I know that sometimes we
do make bad decisions but I try really
hard to follow what God is telling me
and I feel like I just try to trust him
and even if I make a bad decision I feel
like he'll always kind of help me to
straighten it out and help me to find my
way so I can't really I can't really
think of anything that's turned out bad
I guess because I always trust in him
and he always helps me
I think the worst decision that I've
made within the last year does not work
hard enough because I would have worked
harder at the beginning of the year I
probably wouldn't have to have a job
right now my goal is financial freedom I
was working at a camp last summer and I
did a lip-sync to Hilary Duff's why not
and I broke my knee last year and a
lawful house at like 1:00 in the morning
and thought it was a great decision the
next day
realized it was not a great decision
you know so did not settle very well
[Music]
probably not something I'd want to
publicly admit to yeah
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Sariah and i'm
the owner of this channel i'm also the
person behind the camera and i thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you